🎵 I'll take it, I'll tell you Voice behind the shorts, hi hi Like this old man Longing my e-gami, Kimido, no Shinja Shinja Shinja Shinja Shinja Can't you tell me It's all my time Rokinoki, no, no Rokinoki, no, no, no Don't stop, don't stop Let's go, see now.
Let's see, let's see, let's see.
Rocky, rocky, rock, rock, no.
So, Nixon, get-bo.
I've got a good looking.
Ranking up, isn't it?
It's so not very important.
It's very hard to use.
Don't give me your icon.
It's a clear-me-you icon.
It's a easy-to-a-see-c-c-c-see-sticky-manap-boy.
I wish I had a better team.
I wish I would charge it.
How much more careful?
I stalk, I'd talk it.
Yeah, I think it's a good day, go on and it's a day.
Go to be ambitious.
Ha ha, like this all the night In the queue of the time that grinds Take a selfie Selfie Selfie Selfie Selfie Selfie Selfie Selfie That's so it doesn't What's it's about rocky, rocky, rocky, no It's so easy Don't stop, don't stop Let me know why no I can't Yeah but just look to me and see some No
Ocha only go easy to be Slow to go to the snow, the cold Unshinful, unshinful, and it's still there's still a lot.
Actually, there's still a lot of them, cause their voice isn't heard.
Huh?
Deep, компании Deep Baby Baby Baby Baby Baby Baby Baby Don't you know soatorium La Flucky, Root, ROK, roK Now If you hear that loud Is the guitar Don't stop So your flavour Sare, can you please see my life Rocket, rock it, rock it, rock it now Rock it now Rock it now Rock it now Rock it now Sleep it,
it's not It's not it's not it's It's not the world You're the same You're right now you